portland fue el centro de una violenta
jornada que dejó a una persona muerta el
hombre falleció tras recibir un disparo
en el pecho en medio de un tiroteo la
policía abre una investigación por
homicidio pero no ligó la muerte
directamente de las movilizaciones de
partidarios del presidente de donald
trump y del movimiento black lay smarter
que protestaban contra la brutalidad
policial ambos grupos protagonizaron
choques en una ciudad que ha sido
epicentro de fuertes protestas durante
tres medios consecutivos
el alcalde debería avergonzarse de sí
mismo por la demostración de
incompetencia por lo que está sucediendo
en portland y eso está pasando en todas
partes donde están gobernando los
demócratas
[Música]
el tiroteo culminó una volátil semana en
estados unidos que inició cuando la
policía de que no sea en wisconsin
disparó en siete ocasiones contra el
afroamericano jake blake que recibió
cuatro disparos esto desató una ola de
protestas que se mantuvo el fin de
semana con más de mil personas en las
calles pidiendo justicia
mansur mi naturaleza es proteger a mi
hijos defender a mi hijo cuando no puede
ponerse en pie
tú has de mis en estado
preguntan a la policía de este pueblo
que les dio el derecho a intentar
asesinar a mi hijo que les dio el
derecho a pensar que era un animal una
tropa seguro que visitara que no sea el
primero de septiembre en medio de las
críticas por gestionar una dura
respuesta contra los manifestantes
entretanto la inequidad racial mantiene
encendidas las protestas en el país en
donde la policía mata en promedio a unos
tres hombres negros al día según un
estudio reciente de la sociedad
americana de salud pública